Hey, what's up guys? I'm hanging out today with Cody from Cody's lab
He's went down to the coin shop and bought some of these
90% junk Silver coins because we're gonna melt these things down and see if we can turn them into genuine silver bullets
What would you actually use a silver bullet for other than killing a werewolf? I don't know but that's what we're gonna do today
Let's get to it
Apparently there's a lot of different ways that you can melt down silver now if you're on Cody's channel
You can be using some weird experiment like making silver thermite to do this you use a chemical reaction about the silver
But since we're in my basement today. I'm going to be using the mini Arc furnace
It's very small very compact. We can get this thing to extreme temperatures . So there you go guys backyard bullet making 101
Here we go
Now to make an identical copy of our bullets in silver
I'm going to be using some of this petrobond sand it holds together extremely well, and I'll take the shape of our bullets
I'm going to put this wooden retaining wall around it and sprinkle some of the sand and pack it down nice and tight to create
our molds
All right, you can see how well that sand is packed in there now theoretically if we pull those plugs out
We should have little molds. Oh look. Did they come out? Yeah, and actually I'll stuck together brilliant heck
I wish I would have had this stuff when I was making my silver molds
All right guys the time has come we have got everything set up
We've got our molds here ready to go. We've got our Arc furnace carved out ready to go here
We've got our carbon electrodes ready to be fired up
Here's the coins
Think we're just gonna melt the coins right in there because that'll give us the option to pick this up and pour it exactly where we want it to go.
So we've got our silver coins in the Arc furnace now
all we have to do is put on the lid and fire this thing up like so
Oops. It came off. It snapped. What's cool is those coins are almost melted already.
I don't know if you can see that
There you go, you can see that
My bad, that's metal
Here we go check that out guys
The coins are almost melted and that was only about 25 seconds
But unfortunately my carbon rod broke so we're going to do a quick repair and get back into it for a second try I might
be able to just melt this without the lid on it
Check this out guys, so even without a lid we got this thing completely molten that is glowing orange, and it's ready to be poured
It's like the oil in the sand is burning
Here we go at least we got one more bullet out of that
Just give that a little bit of time to cool down, and then I guess we can chop those bullets out of there
What do you think of my Arc furnace? That, is hot.
This is cooled down enough to the point where I can touch it
so I think we can go ahead and dig these bullets out. Over here we've got Cody's bullet from his thermite reaction
Looks like we've got a couple of reasonable casts
Throw those in some water. Cody's is gonna be pure silver and that actually turned out really nice
Yeah, it's a little rough, but the gun will still fire
Here's how our silver coin bullets turned out you can see the shape is pretty good. They're a little bit crude
After sanding and polishing that's what we got cool little silver bullet, okay measuring the weight. We got our copper bullet weighs in at about
124 Grams
exactly our silver bullet weighs in at
94 Grains so it's a little bit lighter which means it's Gonna go a little bit faster check it out guys
This is the original
9-Millimeter bullet used for my glock 19 and these are our silver bullets reloaded into the same casings the bullets are a little bit lighter
weight than the lead
But they should work just fine
All right
Check it out check it out just to do things right we came out here with the silver bullet and a handgun and a werewolf
Target, we're gonna shoot this thing just to see if it actually works or not
Don't know if it's the safest idea, but we're going to give it a shot for your viewing entertainment
So check it out apparently our improvised silver rounds actually do work how cool is that let's check out the damage you hit him?
I think a grazed his shoulder there
Questions if we can recover the bullet
Looks like it's wedged out in there a little ways didn't come out the back so cool. We may be able to recover that
That does have some kick to it
Actually made it through the woods yet. Oh, it came, right through oh dang our silver bullets are powerful. Where did it go?
There it is dude. No way check it out. That actually looks surprisingly intact
Yeah
Looks like it's got a little bit of riflings in it how cool is that guys we could almost take that back and reload it
And shoot it again
This is my favorite silver bullet it came out really you know it looks really shiny it is a little bit pocked
But is that Gonna make a difference to way it shoots and find out right now
Right through the face look at that right through the schnoz
Actually looks like his mouth is open now. That's cool
that was silver it would have got him all right Cody what you got? What are you doing here?
So this is the pure silver bullet short and stubby one should still work though
This is the one that we made with this thermite reaction eat precious metals
Check it out look at the damage
I think it'd be going down after a shot like that. Definitely went into the wood there cool
Let's split it open and see how they look
Doesn't get much better than that. I'll see you one there. Oh sweet. Sweet let me check it out
I went from here to here. That's a that's a reasonable distance. Yeah, it actually looks like it's in really good condition
the wood kind of polished it even
Because I shinier than when I went in yeah, it's the Shelby one. It's our pure silver yep, yay
precious Metal Bullet recovered
ok our several rounds worked and we were able to recover two of the bullets from inside of that stump
Which it's really impressive the condition that these things are in I mean
They're a little bit rough, but almost could just polish them up and reload them use them I didn't have like a red core
So they didn't mushroom or anything. They just went in and stopped. I think they'll do well for the purpose they were designed for
So we have had some success. We made silver bullets from nothing but some silver coins, mini Arc furnace
We melted them down used a sand mold they came out a little bit crude
But you know what we now have some fully functional werewolf deterrent
Which we may or may not ever have to use, but it was a lot of fun
It was so big thanks to cody for conan hanging out today. This is great cody's lab. Go check him out
He's got a lot of experiments with chemicals that I can't pronounce and also on his channel
You're gonna see the termite reaction heated with silver oxide
It is like pure silver is it not this would be fine silver fine silver, so that's awesome. Go check them out cody's lab
Thanks for joining us in this video guys when we looking for you in the next one. Talk to you then
ah ha ha ha ha ha
Subscribe to the caption guy
TechNoDime
or subscribe to the other caption guy, bob bob